braves and marlins game two of their
three-game series coming your way on
this saturday evening where we continue
to remember
and reflect on the 20-year anniversary
of september 11th patriot day here at
the ballpark we'll never forget those
lost on september 11 2001. ftny tin
house was the firehouse located across
the street from the world trade center
where john served as a firefighter for
17 years tonight john is throwing out
the ceremonial first pitch
in honor
of his six brave ladder 10 brothers that
lost their lives
in service
hey guys the man on the mat is on a
great roll too charlie morton paul byrd
he's been worth every penny the braves
have paid him in 2021. i mean look at
these numbers after a really rough start
in april where he couldn't get around
giving up home runs in that big inning
now he is an ace one of the best in all
of baseball after a little mechanical
adjustment staying on track the curb a
key for him and the marlins have first
and third with nobody out and sets the
marlins up for one of their hottest
hitters brian de la cruz nothing in one
from morton that's a ground ball up the
middle a base hit for de la cruz and the
marlins are on the board in the first
inning rbi and jazz goes to third on the
single for de la cruz well the marlins
have showed up to play tonight they look
outstanding against charlie morton who
is facing him for the sixth time this
season now we talked about the breaking
ball de la cruz stayed right on it right
back through the box jazz being
aggressive finds his way over to third
base and rojas scores a great start for
the marlins chisholm's that third day of
the cruise at first one already home one
out brenton batting
brinson goes after the 1-2 pitch and
skies went out to center field this
should be plenty deep for jazz to score
jack peterson makes the play a sac fly
for brinson and another first inning
two-nothing lead for the marlins
deliacer hernandez
who gets the ball tonight for the
marlins making his eighth start of the
season 35th of his career coming off a
no decision against the phillies again
still just trying to finish this season
strong and healthy after having missed a
big chunk of the season in the first
half basically all of it or jorge
solaire traffic aboard is all being
singled to start this ball game 2-2
pitch is hit high in the air and pretty
deep to left-center field but inside the
ballpark for de la cruz here's freddie
freeman
and freeman to the right side and what a
play that was by eddie alvarez to take a
hit away that's why you play him to pull
take every hole away on the right side
of the infield and that was the third
baseman alvarez swung all the way around
now and he's gonna go into the hole on
the short hop down to both knees back up
strong throw to rojas and nearly turned
uh would seem to be an impossible double
play that had a chance to be first and
third for the braves and nearly turned
into an ending ending double play austin
reilly who's been very good this year
payoff pitch
and he does in fact chase it's the first
strikeout of the night for eliezer
hernandez and the side is retired here
in the bottom of the first
so six men came to bat for the marlins
in their two run top of the first now
eddie alvarez will bat getting a start
at third
eddie alvarez with a high fly this one
going deep to right field and it's a
home run in the right field for eddie
alvarez andy alvarez with his first
major league home run and it gives the
marlins a three to nothing lead well
eddie making this a memorable day a
spectacular play defensively a big swing
his first home run as a major leaguer a
no doubter to straight away right up
into the chop house coming in two on lei
diaz
and it was a little long there and
morton disposes of him three pitches for
strikeout number three he is really
struggling from the left side the book
on him he cannot hit that pitch right
there jorge alfaro alfaro strikes out
for the first time two out he's got
eddie alvarez in a 2-2 count
this one chopped dansby's got it fast
runner he's not using speed skates he's
using spikes and he's out number three
morton has a perfect fourth this would
be a big one right here get the crowd
back in the game a lot of room down the
first base line for solaire one ball one
strike driven to right field and the
braves are on the board bobbled by
sanchez in right solaire on his way to
second it's a three to one game you can
get away with one mistake paul but not
two should have never thrown him a fast
ball and i love that solaire bj didn't
try to pull that ball he shot it the
other way
and that's why he's hitting so well here
at truest park i mean he's not afraid to
drive the ball the other way you pitch
it away he'll go away and man he hit
this ball really hard fastball tailing
back in off the corner didn't try to
open his shoulder and hit a home run he
just stayed with that pitch and drove in
the run he ran into charlie morton
getting that inning started so two
doubles one run for atlanta
freddie freeman is coming up
and instead it's a base hit to right
here comes around third sanchez loads up
his throw is up behind ball dropped
anyway base hit for freddie freeman we
got a one-run game another two-strike
hit and it comes with two outs having a
knack but driving in runs that's freddy
freeman talked about 450 with two outs
of runners in scoring position he
continues to get the job done here pitch
down in the zone
running away from him and he reaches out
there and pulls that back change up he
hooked it and how about celaire
running from the start
making it home
easy solar speed
covers a lot of real estate so three
hits in the inning the braves had three
hits in the game until the fifth once
again this innings been magical in the
series now austin reilly is the pitch
base hit here comes freddy he's going to
score
austin riley with an rbi it's a 3-3 game
that had to feel great for austin riley
he got a slaughter up in the zone man in
scoring position the braves continue to
get it done fifth inning the magic two
nights in a row give up two runs early
come back in the fifth and this place
goes nuts austin reilly connecting on a
very good pitch getting the job done
runner goes got a good jump it's on the
ground right at the back diving stop the
braves are going to get it out of it wow
what a play by dansby swanson and i
think atlanta is going to take a look at
it if he turns this double play that is
one for the ages the call was safe is
there enough evidence to show that
swanson had a toe hold
in time to take care of alvarez
every defender but riley's off the field
joe west getting the verdict and he out
what a double play what a fantastic play
by dansby swanson two balls with two
strikes on brian de la cruz
as de la cruz launches one left center
field it's
gone a home run for brian de la cruz and
the marlins take the lead and he has
untied this ball game in the eighth zoo
sanchez here we go baby
and now sanchez drives one right field
and the marlins go back to back the home
run for jesus sanchez to extend it to a
5-3 lead you've got big trouble rojas
coming up first and third one out
there's the bunt santana snuffs it out
throw the plate and they got it the tag
looked to be in the crook of the elbow
did the hand get in first wow that's
pretty close he is safe it is overturned
it's an rbi for rojas
can freddie freeman keep the game alive
the braves are down to their last strike
and it's muscled into right field a big
league at back the braves are going to
bring the tying run to the plate freddie
freeman with his 76th rbi
he is amazing now it's austin reilly
reilly
left center field
brinson's there to make the catch
it's a marlins win they hold off atlanta
6-4 the final score